pondre l'emploi on en a beaucoup parlé
tout à l'heure lors de l'avis de nicolas
sarkozy à la courneuve
c'était le troisième déplacement du
ministre de l'intérieur depuis la mort
d'un enfant de la cité des 4000
c'était lors d'une fusillade entre deux
bandes rivales paul de genève
régis mater troisième visite et premier
bilan pour nicolas sarkozy à la
courneuve
le ministre de l'intérieur avait promis
de revenir ici pour faire le point sur
les mesures qu'il a annoncées il ya un
mois lors de son premier passage après
la mort du jeune sidy ahmed il avait
parlé de nettoyer au kärcher la cité des
depuis différentes opérations policières
ont été menées dans le quartier
le ministre en a aujourd'hui donné les
résultats nous avons procédé à
l'interpellation de sang une personne
je voudrais donc que l'on cesse de
parler des fêtes annonce c'est un
travail de fond que nous engageons et ce
travail prendra fin quand on en sera
débarrassé la cité des trafics et des
trafiquants mais si les associations les
chefs d'entreprises se sont déplacés
aujourd'hui c'est surtout pour entendre
nicolas sarkozy sur le volet de l'emploi
il avait annoncé des embauches et là
encore il est venu avec des résultats
257 embauches directes ont été
recueillis dont 158 à pourvoir
immédiatement des contrats en alternance
des formations qualifiantes ont
également été proposées aux jeunes de la
cité des 4000
mais pour un certain nombre
d'associations présentes aujourd'hui ces
annonces viennent bien tard le travail
est fait sur le terrain simplement ce
qu'il manque c'est un petit peu les
moyens et ce qui est un petit peu
dommage au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
d'attendre qu'il ait fallu la mort d'un
jeune pour que monsieur sarkozy fils
faire son rôle même jour les habitants
de la courneuve attendent maintenant les
effets concrets de ces mesures et ils
pourront à nouveau en discuter que le
ministre de l'intérieur qui a promis de
revenir ici dès l'automne prochain